so joe biden just addressed the u.n
general assembly he declared that
climate change is the biggest crisis in
the world it's your fault but there's a
solution and that solution involves
spending a lot of your money
the scientists and experts are telling
us
that we're fast approaching
a point of no return in a literal sense
in april
i announce the united states will double
our public international financing to
help developing nations tackle the
climate crisis and today i'm proud to
announce that we'll work with the
congress to double that number again
together with increased private capital
and other from other donors
will be able to meet the goal of
mobilizing
100 billion dollars
to support climate action in developing
nations
what exactly is this climate action
you can be positive it's going to make
democratic donors rich but what are the
details we don't know
is the american public pretty excited to
spend billions on foreign countries over
climate change
to check we thought we'd ask brit hume
he's fox news's senior political analyst
he joins us now brett a lot of americans
are very worried about the u.s economy
inflation has hurt them a lot of people
aren't working
and there are signs in the macro economy
that we should be you know paying
attention
is this do you think a time when the
american public will support a plan like
this one
well consider this tucker this is a form
of foreign aid foreign aid has never
been very popular with the american
people who've often had wildly
exaggerated ideas about how much we
spend on it but this is a big number i
mean you know you go back to the obama
level this would be by the time biden
gets finished a quadrupling of that
at a time when he's already asking us to
spend you know
[Music]
1.4 trillion on infrastructure which is
widely supported and another three and a
half trillion on god knows what social
spending
so my guess about this is that it
probably isn't going very far you know
tucker when you ask people in polling if
they think that climate change is a
serious issue
and worthy of concern they also large
numbers say yes
but when you list the priorities it asks
people to list their priorities it's way
down the list i mean in some polls in
some polls i've seen it's not even in
the top 20 it's certainly not in the top
10.
so my guess is that this this proposal
to spend this money uh on something that
is not really
popular isn't going very far
a lot of us has have sincere concerns
about the environment love nature etc
but i'm wondering in all the years
you've covered this have you ever seen a
federal solution to climate change that
disempowers the democratic party of
course well i've never seen any of the
disempowered the government
which some people would say is
synonymous with the democratic party
which is you know long been considered
by most americans the party of
government
so yeah there you are on on that and you
know tucker the uh
one of the things you have to have to
remember here is that this is the u.n
general assembly speech and the whole
speech was you know
sort of leftist boilerplate um you know
china and russia were never mentioned by
name
which gives you an idea how seriously we
ought to take his list of the of the
priorities that are that are facing the
country and nor nor of course what is
the situation that you've been reporting
on with bill malugen on the border so
there you go
that's how seriously to take this speech
brid hume for perspective as always
thank you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else